noticias de economía con Daniela Blandón
Daniela Un saludo para usted nuevamente
y vamos a actualizar las noticias te
parece Sí señora vamos a comenzar con
hilo hermoso que llevado a juicio por
millonarias remuneraciones que recibió
de tesla pues mire Todo comenzó con un
accionista de la marca de autos de lujo
de tesla del hombre más rico del mundo
en un juicio de una semana en un
tribunal de Delaware el baterista
Richard tornetta quien Apenas tenía
nueve acciones cuando presentó esta
demanda en 2018 espera demostrar keylon
musk usó su dominio sobre la junta
directiva de la empresa para elaborar
todo un paquete salarial de 56 mil
millones de dólares y que luego engañó a
los inversionistas para que lo aprobaran
y agrega que lo que buscaba era
financiar su sueño de viajar a marte a
Costa de ellos la defensa dice que esa
remuneración que es la más alta de la
historia para un ejecutivo fue legal
porque El Magnate había conducido la
empresa por un período bastante
turbulente turbulento y preciso que el
precio de las acciones se disparará por
10 este lunes testificaron dos ex
ejecutivos de la empresa y el propio
elon musk lo va a hacer mañana miércoles
a propósito también Ángela antes de que
pasemos al siguiente tema de Twitter el
ex presidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump solicitó el lunes a un tribunal de
apelaciones que reviva su demanda en la
que pide que se le reactive su cuenta
que fue suspendida permanentemente luego
de que sus seguidores atacarán el
Capitolio en 2021 Twitter porque y lonos
también es dueño de entender y había que
meter el tema ahora Walmart te acordó
millonarios compensaciones por el mal
uso de opioides en Estados Unidos como
es el caso Bueno Este es el mayor
empleador de Estados Unidos y acordó a
pagar $3.100 millones de dólares para
resolver demandas en todo el país por el
impacto que han tenido los analgésicos
opioides que por décadas ha vendido en
sus farmacias sin haber alertado de los
peligros para la salud de consumirlos El
acuerdo aún debe ser aprobado por 43
estados para que entre en vigor pero se
une o amarte así a otros Grandes como
Walgreens o CVS que lograron pacto
similares hace pocos días todos suman
estos alumnos 50 mil millones de dólares
y los gobiernos estatales y locales
deben usar la mayor parte de esos
recursos para combatir la adicción a los
opioides que sea relacionado con más de
500 mil muertes en Estados Unidos
durante las últimas dos décadas en otros
temas Amazon Me podría unirse a otras
grandes tecnológicas en realizar
despidos masivos pues lo anticipó el
periódico de New York Times que dijo que
por posiblemente esta semana por lo
menos 10.000 trabajadores de Amazon
perderían su puesto la empresa todavía
no ha hecho oficial El despido lo que sí
hizo hace dos semanas fue decir que
Había decidido pausar la contratación
corporativa porque la economía estaba en
un lugar incierto pero Amazon no es la
única también hay otras empresas
tecnológicas
los tiempos son oscuros en tecnología lo
estamos viendo en Amazon Apple Microsoft
y otros
El reloj marcó la medianoche en el
hipercrecimiento y ahora se están viendo
los cortes en todos los ámbitos
muchas de esas empresas de tecnología
gastaron como estrellas de rock de la
década de 1980 en los últimos años y en
medio de la resaca de crecimiento
posterior al covid así como una recesión
a la vuelta de la esquina se están
comenzando a ver costos que deben
eliminarse de los negocios pienso mucho
en lo que llamaré proyectos monchot o
áreas no estratégicas ahora se están
comenzando a ver recortes en esas áreas
cayó inesperadamente la economía de
Japón Ángela en este tercer trimestre
que terminó en septiembre el producto
interno bruto de la tercera Economía del
mundo se contrajo en 1,2%. sorprendiendo
a los analistas que estaban esperando
una expansión Es la primera vez que cae
en un año y esto lo que hace es todavía
más esos temores sobre una posible
recesión global además de estar
atravesando por su octava ola de
contagios y por covid 19 y también por
enfrentar las consecuencias de las tasas
de interés altas en todo el mundo Japón
ha estado lidiando con el desafío de la
caída del yen que hoy está en mínimos de
32 años frente al Dólar y Daniela
también se conocieron datos de la zona
Euro en los 19 países que comparten la
moneda el producto interno bruto creció
2,1% si lo medimos frente al mismo
trimestre del año pasado esto estamos
hablando tercer trimestre el empleo
también lo hizo en 1,7%. pero si
comparamos este esta cifra con el
trimestre anterior el aumento es menor
es por eso que la comisión europea
Espera que la economía se contraiga en
el cuarto trimestre de 2022 y en los
primeros tres meses de 2023 debido al
aumento de los precios de la energía y
de las tasas de interés
muy bien Daniela Pues el agradecimiento
a usted por esta actualización de los
temas económicos por hoy ya se puede ir
a descansar volveremos mañana con más
temas le deseo feliz desayuno gracias